hey friends welcome desk IJ in the last
episode you guys asked me questions in
the YouTube comments and here I am
answering some of them some of them I
don't know where you guys come up with
these things and you should probably be
in jail
you guys this last episode of ask guy
Jake feel free to go watch it I want to
watch it that's fine let's start this
episode with a question from Shelby
Daughtry who's asking what am I gonna be
for Halloween I haven't really thought
that far ahead
last year I wore a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle onesie which was absolutely the
most comfortable outfit ever
Dada have you ever done stuff like face
surgery sparse face surgery goes do you
consider a wisdom tooth being ripped out
of your face because if so then yes
that's I've had my wisdom teeth out
how's Ryan asks Carly he's he's great
christian klemenz is asking if i can do
a double twisting your chick with a lot
don't think i can do that i might be
able to do a handstand is it real name I
just need or is that just your stage
name and your real name is John Stein my
real name is Justine not John Stein and
if it was I probably would have changed
it by now your name is John Stein that's
that's great I'm glad for you I don't
know what your parents were thinking
they hopefully weren't drunk while they
were having you because I don't think
that's good for the baby but mmm
Ben's really asking how I make my hair
so nice
guitar dad's is asking we'll take a
camera I'm using to shoot this video I
am using a Canon 60d question answered
mrs. Skeeter girl Insano an episode of
ask IJ I'm on I have absolutely no idea
what would you if you're asking five
turned into a tree which turned into a
wizard and then the lizard zapped you
and turned you into turtle the lips in
the desert they can only eat fish or you
will die
Emmy are you okay do you want me to call
you some doctors should I refer you some
medical health what are you talking
about that's what I do
I'm call 9-1-1 somebody call nine one
we've got some fast running in a tree
he's uh um hi yeah this is number one my
emergency oh I keep forgetting about the
segment so put me in an ask i J episode
segment where are you guys leave me
comments and I just hit you then here
see see this comment leave all of your
comments or questions below and you may
or may not see your question in next
week's episode I'll see you guys later
I love you don't worry subscribe and um
hi